ouais bien alors on dit souvent des
nausées
sur les plateaux de télévision et des
fois même dans cette émission
alors je vous faire pierre palmade une
interview avec des beats alors pierre
c'est vrai que vous aimez beaucoup faire
un après spectacle
j'aimais au début et puis c'est fini
l'âge venant j'étais obligé tient en
amour vous êtes plutôt ou plutôt à la
pause toujours celle là bas bip
forcément ça vous habitez dans la vie
d'être pour réussir à alors j'hésite
entre bobo ça peut être drôle ça m'a
beaucoup pays vous connaissez bien
michèle laroque on vous a dit qu'ici
même sur ce plateau l'année dernière les
mois on a des taux courants oui vous
l'avez vu à la télé oui régné sur le bip
et avec véro vous avez wii jeu malgré ce
qu'on pense oui
et cette histoire avec on en parle où on
peut en parler ou pas stationner
n'importe quoi ah bon c'est n'importe
quoi
si je vous dis vous pensez accrocheur
à bord de leur régie
l'ergonome
non